do welcome everybody to the
post-presidential podcast I am your host
and kingmaker ethan klein
wanker yes I'm the king that's what you
call someone who is the gateway to great
power that's me so if any other
presidential candidates hopefuls want to
come pass through the gate I can make a
king make I can make you a king I'm the
kingmaker of course I'm referencing our
last podcast with Andrew yang
presidential hopeful of the Democratic
Party had a great great conversation
with him yeah feel very honored to have
had him come through our studio and I
highly recommend you guys checking that
out it was it was a really good
conversation I enjoyed myself very much
Andrew what a what a guy huh I mean
really super cool super done the earth
super cool super smart it's just nice
day you can have like a conversation
with him like a normal person
just hanging out kind of thing all right
thank you to our sponsors true hems and
daddy fresh the huge restock new shirt
that he was wearing this shirt was
restocked Teddy fresh calm ahead oh
sorry to cut you off we have obligations
I was saying that I can't imagine having
such a conversation with any other
candidate like can you imagine someone
like Joe Biden no because they just
wouldn't stick to the it wouldn't
wouldn't happened they'd stick to the
script and that's what's so unappealing
about all of them you don't know what
any of them think or feel because
they're all just telling the line yeah I
mean is there any one else I would like
to have in here Bernie Sanders you did
Rogen though and I mean he was great I
was really impressed with Bernie because
he really toes the line in most debates
and interviews it's always like the two
percent of the 20 percent 10 percent of
this country owns 2% of all the wealth
and 50 percent the 50 percent of the 100
percent but he actually will had a
really good conversation with Joe and
anyway we had some what's up EULA sir I
don't know why this laptop will always
sign out no matter what we do
sign out of what of our Google so now I
don't have the document open well again
well uh yeah all my lead hmm Michael
avenatti came off of the yang gang do
you not know the password no you should
just tell her the password this is very
it wants to watch him
Michael avenatti was talking [ __ ] to
andrew yang after our interview
yeah if you guys remember Michael and
vanity he was stormy Daniels lawyer this
guy was in the media everywhere he was
talking about running for president it
was blowing up we're like whoa
so Andrew made a comment on the podcast
he said last time I was in Iowa speaking
Michael avenatti was there and he made a
tweet like that we were saying how times
have changed because Michael avenatti
soon after blowing up he found like
guilty of a lot of really amazing
darlink Salcha prison so closing on him
yeah scumbag he's awaiting trial yeah
that guy's [ __ ] he's going to prison
for a long time he stole money from
clients he lied to help people I mailed
Nike right he write that was the big
story I mean that guy is a [ __ ] idiot
he goes he tries blackmailing Nike and
Nike is like sure yeah and meanwhile
they're meet it were like hey FBI this
guy's blackmailing me and the FBI was
like uh dude it's an IT bro
Nike the guy's so arrogant so anyway
Michael avenatti tweeted out at Andrew
I'm really glad I found it cuz he erased
it everyone started slamming on him spot
I was surprised that that wait so like
how to know some class like well and and
and and choose what tweet wasn't really
amatory that much she said no last time
I spoke at the wingding the final
speaker was Michael avenatti times have
changed thankfully well I guess the
thankfully is a little jab you are good
you are a you know criminal be real with
that and you did it with some class in
my opinion and then arrayed Michael ever
not his response well he certainly
didn't tag him or anything you know so
avenatti comes out of the cuts like oh
did somebody say my name which is
clearly like either has a notification
for when someone tweets at him or
searches his name and he says they
haven't changed that much you still have
no shot at the nomination none and let
me remind you the reception my remarks
received and he linked to a article from
The Guardian Michael of and I says
Democrats was fire with fire okay well
apparently whatever yeah dude
a lots of change bro so then then Andrew
came out with the zinger wait this
where's Andrews Inger I said to him
Michael I would say yang has a much
better chance than you considering
you're in prison will be will be but
it's a good it's a nice gaff and I
further said well we got to protect the
yang game yeah dude I'm yang game for
life and I go wait I'll go wait hold on
Michael can one run can one run for
president from prison please let us know
and he blocked me I told my mom I was
okay my gob and out he just blocked me
she said it was good for someone with
such a big mouth he sure can't take it
you know he sure is sensitive what a
bitch-ass blocking people honk yeah
don't don't even come at my yang my gang
boy by the way yang had a great response
to which already - oh here's blocked why
did I not save Andrews response I
thought I had it here can you give me
that Dan can you pull that up yeah I'm
pulling it up so yeah avenatti blocked
me which is really which is kind of a
beautiful thing it means you've read my
tweets and was so agitated
under his skin and he dropped the block
on me here it is thank you Dan and
that's that is why you don't block
because now you're giving us money and
now I'm talking about in the show I'm
like oh this little bitch-ass blocked me
mute dude mute if you can't handle it
but you know why I came to a realization
hmm you block because it prevents people
from interacting with your tweets and
that you can control the narrative I see
yeah like sometimes I look at a tweet
and I'll be like why aren't there people
slamming on this guy right now it's cuz
they blocking everybody and then all the
haters it can't respond so it's like
total total [ __ ] censorship mode that's
why the that's why courts ruled the
Donald Trump can't legally block people
on Twitter Wow Trump's blocking a ton of
people on Twitter can you imagine the
president spends his time blocking that
really happen yes and the courts decided
it's unconstitutional for Trump to block
people on Twitter oh my guess what he
has not unblocked them and people are
suing the president because they're
blocked is that not epic day I feel like
we're in a black Camaro episode like
everything just the court is ruling
about you blocking someone well it's
it's one it's a it is but it makes sense
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh he oh there's a
new response he offered well hold on let
me go to Andrew so because I was in the
room Michael you have bigger problems
than fond memories of your pretend run
good luck
you just got ganged on that was a [ __ ]
slam dunk I love that you've got bigger
problems than your fond memories good
luck Oh your pretend run Michael
responded mister less than 1% actually
3% bet she already made it to the final
debates [ __ ] and let me remind you
Michael
in prison prison boy avenatti that Trump
was at 1% this time last year prison
Matty was pretty naughty not last year
this time during you know what I mean
yeah right during the last election
cycle thank you Dan
thank you very much god bless you
Prison Adi Michael you've been naughty
so you going to prison
less than 1% you were running for
president supposedly and yet you're
still obsessing over my reception
bro that is not one of them realize that
he's he's simply using it as a metric of
of how much has changed in a year dude
no one's obsessing over your reception
at an event one year ago and how nobody
paid attention to what you had to say
get over it and get out of the race
you're embarrassing yourself dude this
guy is such a tool this guy oh my god I
have to recite there I want to respond
to live on the show right now
no but you can't you're blocked there
you go and that's why I blocked you
exactly you see my blog this is such
pathetic low character response I would
say something like if anyone is obsessed
it's him why are you why do you care
that is he didn't even tag you you creep
you know but why does he care that he's
running he keeps saying get over it get
out of the race because he's butthurt
that he made a slight at him and he's a
petty little [ __ ] [ __ ] ass oh maybe
he didn't erase it he just blocked me so
it says unavailable you see the power of
the block you control the narrative so I
believer in non blocking I've never I
don't have anyone blocked and you can
you can take that to the bank
at least I think so I may have one or
two kids blocked from a long time ago so
don't go around there trying to expose
me because I have your [ __ ] dumbass
blocked with ten follows but I'm pretty
sure I don't have anyone blocked
okay but guess what I could if I wanted
I'm not the [ __ ] president you know
what I'm saying I don't hold public
office I would say to Michael if I could
tweet at him I would say he knows who's
obsessed
[Music]
you know who's obsessed with you
the Nike lawyers who are gonna put you
in prison I don't know no good right
see that's why you don't twit on the
show needs you gotta think about minutes
yeah get out of the race you're
embarrassing yourself Michael you're
Michael embarrassing yourself
bro anyway whatever that guy's such a
tool man Michael avenatti bro what's it
do you tweeted at yeah hey dude you're
so pathetic you blocked me you said
gangs embarrassing himself bro oh damn
this guy's such a tool he was like
really popular for a minute I know he
was on Bill Maher people were taking him
seriously I was enjoying the show for a
moment he seemed cool but then very
quickly things have changed like yank
pointed out I've been naughty all right
moving on let's move on oh and since
we're on the politics you're so
politically Ethan yeah well what can I
do it's a political time we've got an
election coming up there's a lot at
stake you got shootings every day I mean
what the [ __ ] dude how do you not care
about this stuff I mean I've tried for
the longest time I want to talk about
this photo cuz it's so classic
here's Trump at the El Paso hospital
this orphan lost both of his parents at
the shooting at Walmart in El Paso hit
the child is a parentless he's an orphan
and Donald Trump and the first lady show
up at the hospital the story as it was
reported is that the child was
discharged from the hospital already and
the White House requested to have the
baby back for a photo op so here's
Donald Trump with a big smile and a
thumbs up in the first lay with a big
smile to commemorate this beautiful day
this future Trump supporter hey I'm
surprised I didn't put a little make
America great hat on him you know it's
like you may have lost your parents but
you'll always have this pick
to cherish this picture it makes me so
upset I don't even have words to
describe I hate it
get your hands off that babe you have
nothing to do with that baby why are you
holding him most of I even using him as
an accessory for a picture well that's a
great point you look because most of the
patients at the hospital refused to be
visited by Trump because of most people
no think that he's response
his rhetoric his words are partially
responsible for you know inciting that
kind of violence
so most people said no this baby
unfortunately who lost both of his
parents is incapable of saying no and so
they were unable to get many photo
opportunities but they were able to get
a hold of this baby who was already
discharged and brought back to the
hospital so thumbs up make mega mega
mega I saw an article today that um
they're offering classes to kids who
were going back to school now everyone's
going back to school
on how to treat wounds and stop bleeding
and I thought I grew up in a [ __ ] up
environment in Israel seriously I mean
we used to have drills at school in
elementary school what happens when
there's like a siren or a terrorist
attack or something and everyone had to
run to save and I just can't believe
that this is happening here because when
I moved here I was like this is this is
like euphoria like California is amazing
so beautiful you've all the opportunity
in the world and like America is so
great and then this show is happening
here I almost like I feel safer in
Israel all of a sudden well you know
that's why if I can move on skip ahead a
little bit to Neil smoke deGrasse
Tyson's worst weight of all time he goes
because I think what he's missing here
he even taking his tweet at face value
which i think is just stupid and awful
but he's what he's missing is the
terrorism yeah it's psychological
terrorism you cannot put
a number on that this tweet really upset
me this guy he's so this tweet is so
pathetic I'm gonna break it down because
a lot of people seem to think that this
is a permanent irrational thing to say
Nilda crass and in the immediate
aftermath of these back-to-back
shootings said in the past 48 hours the
USA horrifically lost 34 people to mass
shootings on average across any 48 hours
we also lose 502 medical errors by the
way this number is hotly contested in
the comments 302 the flu 252 suicide 200
a car accidents 42 homicide via handgun
often our emotions respond more to
spectacle than to data well first of all
the timing bro the [ __ ] timing yeah
and and and second of all what is he
trying to what is he trying to do with
this tweet yeah it's hard to say I mean
he's trying to put it in the context I
guess and saying hey it's not that bad I
mean is it really is that what he's
trying to say I don't know what other
he's trying to say he's going like look
we're all getting super upset about you
know these mass shootings but it's
really not that big of a deal
also excuse me for getting emotional I'm
are we allowed to get emotional I don't
sign it's not a bad thing all of a
sudden
yes I'm emotional I think I don't want
to hear about a baby dying because
someone shot him or a baby not having
parents now cuz someone shot his parents
well that's just because you respond
more to spectacle than data according to
Neil no ma'am
human being with emotions the comparison
is so tone deaf I mean it's just it's
honestly for someone who's supposed to
be so smart this is one of the dumbest
things I've ever heard to the flu do you
not think we're trying to prevent people
from dying from the flu bro we've been
trying to find a cure to the flu for
since we [ __ ] knew that vaccines were
thin what do you think we're not doing
about the flu mm-hmm he's implying that
somehow we should be more worried about
these what can I do about the flu Neil
there's already the flu
people are not taking it people diet flu
it's the flu the flu it's the flu it's
killed more people than anything it's
the flu Neal why should a random
horrific mass shootings be even
comparable to the flu the flu it kills
people Neal what am i son medical errors
what am I supposed to do about medical
errors hotly-contested figure by the way
I'm sure the hospital has their own
procedures to handle those errors yeah
hey hey guys we should be more worried
about medical errors the problem is that
it feels like no one is doing anything
about mass shootings and by the way and
this is why everyone's getting so
emotional and it's and they should be
well Neal's saying it's not an issue
then what do you think about his tweet
yes yeah I mean like you said I think
you know it's it is rational to get
upset about something that is
preventable happening you know what I
mean and it's like I mean I do
understand what he's trying to say but
like you said it's just so what is he
trying to say what is he trying to say
well he's trying to say just like from a
a completely you know detached way you
know not that big of a deal it's he's
trying to point out like how people are
more afraid of dying in a plane crash
than dying in a car accident even though
you're way more likely to die in a car
accident and it's like yeah I understand
that point Tom but regardless it's like
it's not operable because so let me
write out Neil deGrasse Tyson tweet on
September 12th okay the day after the
the world trip yeah he goes he goes uh
you know we did lose 3,000 people to a
terrorist attack but the flu in that
same amount of time within a week kills
more people so it's very so really we
don't need to worry about that yeah also
I don't know for me growing up in Israel
there's oh there was always like there
would be a new trend of terrorist attack
like they'll have a new kind of thing
that works that they figure it out too
get to people but then what you would
see is the government taking action
towards that new thing right and you
would see changes right things will be
addressed you'll have a few terror
attacks and then they figure out a way
to stop it until there is a new kind but
there is nothing happening here nobody's
doing anything well and and and part of
why this tweet is so bad is that he's
kind of I feel like this is a right-wing
or a gun NRA talking point that he's
kind of parroting and I've seen this
tweet being celebrated by like NRA and
people like that who are opposed to gun
change because he what he's saying is
basically hey this isn't it this isn't a
problem we're all over over responding
to it but the truth is that with 250
mass shootings this year I don't think
that any sane person could say that the
status quo is fine you know what's funny
is the - two of the items here 250 -
suicide that's usually gun vodka bite by
guns and 40 by handgun I don't know why
he even included that you [ __ ]
imbecile
he's also gun violence it's so weird
because we all know that is a really
smart intelligent guy I mean you keep
saying your embassy which i understand
why you're saying it seems like the
dumbest to it I'm considering the timing
of it which just doesn't make sense to
me why would he do that 200 a car
accidents yeah well hmm well I guess at
this point since 200 people did die in a
car accident I guess I shouldn't worry
about all the mass shootings 34 people
well also a lot more people used to die
in car accidents and then we implemented
a bunch of laws to make cars safer and
mandatory seatbelts and all kinds of
things you know we we took action on
that right and the point is that
everything he listed here is stuff that
we are trying to improve with the
exception of suicide and handguns which
is kind of part of the same issue I
don't know
but it it doesn't make sense it doesn't
in any way the the bigger part that is
missing is the terrorism right like and
not it shouldn't be under the same kind
of medical error look at [ __ ]
al-qaeda they blew up the World Trade
Center and they [ __ ] our whole society
up comparatively it's not that much
damage but it's the Terrorism it's the
psychological warfare that that's that's
that's the real that's really damaging
it so it's cities that everyone in that
area of where something happened will be
traumatized forever it's so much damage
so what he's saying in his really really
empathetic tweet is hey don't even trip
dog not that big of a deal chances are
you're not gonna be killed by a by a
homegrown terrorist just smoke the grass
Tyson yeah smoke the grass mom anyway I
thought this was just the trashiest
thing I ever read and then he tried to
explain it and like a follow up thing
and I still don't
oh really yeah he made it an apology
that I just saw this morning that was
hanging and I closed my [ __ ] document
I don't know I thought it was so dumb
hold on me
yeah daddy let's talk also what's
annoying is that right after a shooting
people are like don't talk about it now
it's too soon you know let the families
and have their moment and then if you
keep talking about it people are like
can you move on we want something a
little more
so that's part of light-hearted that's
part of the strategy of avoiding this is
part of the the propaganda strategy they
that argument worked for a long time
they say oh don't politicize it and then
so okay I have to wait and then you lose
the moment yeah and now well now the new
strategy is they're blaming video games
and I've got a whole clip a whole
segment of them blaming video games and
it's all Fox News and it's then the
president himself comes out and blames
video games they know it's not video
games to blame they know that they'll
never change that all they're trying to
do is redirect and and off and like
confuse the conversation so that in a
week and two weeks I mean it's already
forgotten then we stopped caring about
gun control it's it's dude and you know
the other argument is people say they
want to take all of our guns away no
dude these all these shootings are
[ __ ] military rifles we're pretty far
from taking all guns - I'm leaving I'm
gonna wanted to do that that's not gonna
happen I'm a gun owner I like my gun I
like having my gun have a shotgun at my
house okay handguns shotguns hunting
rifles
god bless dude but their military just
needs to be new procedures when
something this happened you gotta add
more rules you know you gotta add for
example background checks or like in
Israel there was a something that
happened a while ago with like a guard
using his handgun so then they made a
law where the guards have to leave their
handguns at work let's say they can take
it with them you know there's things
that you can do to prevent stuff
right yeah nothing happens they always
say the Conservatives the gun pro-gun
people say like it's a mental health
issue okay what are we doing about
mental health that's nothing
well they say no no it's not the guns
I've identified the issue okay so what
are we doing about that issue nothing
they never do anything oh yeah I just
see that talking point a lot like it's
not the gun it's the person okay so what
are we doing about that you know well
Let Me Entertain You not just a person
and the person used the gun but let's
even just say they're right so what are
we doing about that yeah nothing then
nothing ever gets done weak pathetic
people weak come on do it 250 this year
what are we [ __ ] doing here why are
we as a country allowing this to happen
you know most people are in favor of
some common sense gun laws background
checks you know there was like there was
legislation to prevent people with a
history of mental illness from getting
guns and guess what the [ __ ] a
Republican Party blocked it Mitch
McConnell or whoever [ __ ] the Kentucky
what says what's what's that this isn't
a Mitch Mitch McConnell said oh right
miss Whelan oh yeah he blocked it
because apparently preventing people
with mental illness their own talking
point is that it's a mental illness
problem and so when there's bipartisan
legislation the block mental people with
a history of mental illness from getting
guns they block that mm-hmm does heaven
can do with the NRA that contributed
like two million dollars to his campaign
is that funny only two million dollars
that's all it takes to enable 250 mass
shootings to occur it's just a couple
million dollars to help him get
reelected pretty cheap pretty cheap I
mean for the death of like some kids and
[ __ ] and hundreds of people million
bucks it's a pretty cheap man yeah
so I'll read his apology and then I'm
gonna go into the video games cause
violence mium thumbs up guys hey took
kids out there who died and lost their
parents Magga I feel like Trump's losing
it you know I know there's a probably
some Trump support I mean there's a lot
of Trump sports listen the show on the
internet particular there's a lot of
Trump supporters I think he's losing it
I don't know me I understand why people
voted for him at the time but please
reconsider
look at the other options he's losing it
dude I really think so I mean the guy
spends all day blocking people on
Twitter well not anymore
well who says I thought he's not allowed
to anymore he still does he has an
unblocked the people that's what I was
saying but I don't think he's blocking
new people I don't know I mean he's
they're they're suing him again we
should still unblock the people our
block they're probably well that was
what the lawsuit was about right right
right
and he still has not unblocked them I
can't get over this picture all right be
best baby dumped up
it's almost 30 minutes should we
continue or take a break we've got let's
look at the apology dance tell me we're
at 30 minutes a rudder
Bing Bing bong bong there's some really
slow change the mood it feels so heavy
change the mode you know that's the
problem when you talk about this stuff a
lot we've got funny stuff on deck just
following the thread look it's not
always laffs and gaffs and rainbows
mm-hmm
you know this was a great one everybody
mass shootings are bad neil degrasse
tyson this is dr. Manhattan like the god
character from Watchmen he goes a live
body and a dead body contain the same
number of particles structurally there's
no discernible difference life and death
are unquantifiable abstracts why should
I be concerned that's a good point
argue with the facts I only have to read
it like five times
it's a lot of text for me I don't know
what that that that was the perfect name
though I love that so let's read his
apology on Facebook he went straight to
Facebook he's like oh I'm gonna get
roasted on Twitter I came only gonna go
to hey he calls it tweet storm he says
if you missed it I offered a short list
of largely largely preventable causes of
death flu how are we presenting how are
we preventing deaths from the flu you
[ __ ] idiot
car crashes how are we preventing deaths
from car cars we are doing our best he
says a list of largely preventable
causes of death I don't think that's
right well we are doing what we can yeah
we're doing what we can that's my point
short of not driving cars how are we
gonna prevent deaths from car crashes
right soon that's very true point eula
along with our average to day death toll
in the United States I love the idea of
Neil deGrasse being like these
back-to-back terrible shootings happen
in Neil's iconic let me get these stats
car deaths okay perfect I'm crafting my
beautiful tweet suicide numbers medical
errors right not a big deal is it folks
they significantly exceeded the death
toll from the two days of mass shooting
he's like trying to justify including
the number of people who on average die
from handgun violence every two days I
then noted that we tend to react
emotionally to spectacular incidents of
data yeah okay we read the TWiT that's
why we're here you don't need to dude
he's so epic how he understands human
nature can break it down in a way that I
could understand I totally I totally
feel so much better now about these
shootings now that I understand the 200
people died from car from car accidents
in that same amount of time I totally
feel so much better about mass shooter
doesn't want us to get more upset at the
other stuff like when people are already
upset right is that as far as I'm gonna
go to get us more upset about the other
I think he was trying to make people
feel better by saying by trying to show
you that it's not that serious
I mean I with the implication that more
common causes of death by the way and
and you know he's he's putting mass
shootings next is something like the flu
okay that should not be in a comparable
statistic that's there that's a lot of
people dying from mass shootings my
intent was to offer offer objectively
true information that might help shape
conversations and reactions to
preventable lives meantime where I
miscalculated was that I genuinely
believe between would be helpful to
anyone trying to save lives in America
what I learned from the range of
reactions is that for many people some
information might wheat in particular
can be true but unhelpful so I was right
but you guys just weren't ready for him
especially at a time when many people
are either still in shock or trying to
heal or both if you are one of those
people I apologize if not knowing in
advance what effect might one of those
on you one of those it is so if you're
one of those [ __ ] imbeciles who can't
handle a little dose of objective
reality I am therefore I am therefore
thankful for the candor and depth of
critical reaction shared in my Twitter
feed as an educator I personally value
knowing with perception precision and
accuracy what reaction anything I say or
write well and still in my audience and
this one then I get wrong respectfully
submitted mother [ __ ] what you just
sign off as that is right truly yours
hate Twitter war yeah just right yeah
yours truly I mean this is a really desi
apology it should suck so much man its
objective truth and preventable doubts
thank you saying I didn't know that that
many of you are gonna be so dumb and you
would take it so wrong he's like look
only 32 people died and there's two or
three hundred million so how could you
all have been so affected by this I'm
only about a thousand people could have
been affected firsthand
mr. Zhu is truly [ __ ] makes me miss Carl
Sagan's so much yeah Carl Sagan oh mama
I I read this I'm like you know what
Neal for those reasons and for those
reasons amount I was like dude anyway
there you have it folks let's take a
break when we come back we've got the
videogames or to blame for shootings
guys so we've got a revelation here we
figured it out all right let's fix it
all together when we come back from this
commercial break you know did you know
that 66% of all men start losing their
hair by the age 35 I did because I heard
this you've heard this from oh yeah well
it's scary and it's true and guys are
not doing enough to keep that beautiful
head of hair on their head where it
belongs
okay it makes a big difference I'm not
even talking about cuties you want to
[ __ ] you because you have a big
beautiful head of hair no I'm also
talking about the Sun you want cancer on
your head cuz you're bald gonna be stuck
putting sunscreen on your head well it's
real we got to do something about it
there's no reason to do nothing in this
day and age we're in the future okay
we've got science and we've got doctors
that can help you right now
for hemes calm is the solution it's a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men these are real
prescriptions backed by science there's
no waiting room no awkward in-person
doctor visits you're gonna save hours by
going to four hems calm all you do is
answer a few quick questions and a real
doctor will review and give you a real
prescription to keep that hair beautiful
and glowing and flowing so order right
now my listeners are gonna get a
one-month trial for hims for just $5
today right now while supplies last
see website for full details and safety
information this would cost hundreds if
you went to a doctor of pharmacy so keep
that head on your hair where it belongs
god damn it go to forums dot-com slash
h3 that's fo r hims comm slash h3 for
hams com
a ch3
teddie fresh calm is a cool place to get
clothing that you can wear it's hip it's
fresh it's cooled and it's designed by
yours truly the way this is yours truly
can I ask my own self for a mate good
you do a shitty ad read but me neither
own this company so can I ask myself for
a free ad read I make good yeah I'm
sorry Ethan but you don't pronounce
teddy fresh calm properly there's some
[ __ ] if you say dot-com you owe us a
free read so I yeah you didn't say
dot-com anyway either why are we talking
about Teddy fresh I don't know let me
see your shirt brand new shirt the yin
yang baby stand up let's get along gang
stand up model that okay beautiful love
it love it love it
look at the screen here we've got also
got it in black and white this one's hot
as it gets I mean it's hot as it gets
folks look at this shirt I mean guys
it's hot as it gets
ah okay don't try so hard
I need more guidance I need cops trying
a little too hard eating okay when we
turn it down we've also got back in
stock everyone's favorites we've raced
it may be one of the biggest three
stocks we brought back all the
color-block colors that's the hernia for
all three colors in stock and the one
next to the ice cream hoodie and the TF
hoodie and the shirt we've got the
fullest limit the most wanted act now
while supplies last and there's some new
[ __ ] you know whatever just go to Teddy
fresh tuck I'm look around see if
there's something you like gah beige
anything else to do mm-hm
okay back to the show guys thank you
you know people often react to spectacle
but there's 2300 high-rises in New York
and the World Trade Center was only two
buildings so statistically it really
wasn't that big of a deal
we often relate to inspect the Colvin
effect I want to show you before we get
into video games things Joe Biden had a
great gaff for everyone who thinks I'm
just here about over the Conservatives I
mean here look at your boy Biden whose
brain is melting before our eyes we
should do is you should challenge these
students we should challenge students in
these schools they have Advanced
Placement programs in these schools we
have this notion that somehow if you're
poor you cannot do it poor kids are just
as bright in just his talents white kids
wealthy kids black top then he goes on
to say he saves it by saying by listing
other races more kids are just as smart
do it poor kids are just as bright and
just as talyn's white kids how great is
that the best one ever
orcas are just as bright as white kids
how brave the brave stands to take
[Applause]
everyone's like no no no no I really do
mean it poor kids are just as smart as
white kids Asian kids you know poor is
not a race Asian kids I I think Joe
Biden and his prime was a he look don't
forget texted three calm no he didn't
even say flash he said go to he said it
was the best moment he pulled that up I
want to find it he goes I was watching
that live and I was like what he goes go
to Joe
303 303 he doesn't say calm he doesn't
say tax this says go to Joe 303 three
giving its phone number call me and ask
for Joe so what he meant to say it's one
of those like text by them to make it
was 20/20 because I was like wow it's
not good everyone had a really good URL
like yes no you can see it and open that
clip you were looking at now I just gave
you the clip why did they choose that as
their thing because everyone was like
yang 20/20 calm I was like oh that's
easy to remember
then he was like what's with the three
oh three three like it doesn't really
make any sense if you agree with me go
to Joe 303 303 what is good it's like
Joe wanna help if you open that a clip
that we were just watching about the
white kids yeah you can see on the
stadium it says it is it is text number
you're supposed to say Joe to 303 303
303 300 M is not gonna win I'll tell you
why it's literally because of that
[ __ ] raising [ __ ] money
next Iowa to 303 300 that is so bad why
not just Joe 2020 dot-com
I don't know vote Joe 2020 dot-com dude
I don't understand I've seen other
marketing people doing this texting it's
awful
give me a URL I'm not texting anyone
anything I don't even use text anymore
texting is for savages and brutes I
don't text savage yeah it's for [ __ ]
low-tech losers they're savage Oh like
yes they're plebeian scumbags poor but
they're just as smart as were you
thinking savage like how Jake Falls yeah
meaning it actually has a it actually
has a meaning it means not anymore
I'm uncultured a savage is someone who's
uncultured well you're on cultured if
you don't know what Savage means well
that's you know what savage me you text
Joe watch this again no this is my
favorite thing so far out of this whole
thing
if you agree with please go to Joe 303
threefold then it's a bad bad place to
get other people to go well you know I
could see even myself because it's just
Joe 303 three three three yo and then
mine he's like cool [ __ ] anyway did you
know that video games are responsible
for all the mass shootings I've heard
you say it well here's the proof it's
all somehow being reported on Fox News
and then finally parodied by yours truly
and I don't mean OJ Simpson you want a
you even these individuals what they
wrote in others but I mean this may be a
place that this is a Republican House
minority face of what what's being
written can be changed to be an
indication that an individual needs help
and others that we can stop but the idea
of these video games to dehumanize
individuals to have a game of shooting
individuals and others I've always felt
that is a problem for really a future
generation I've always felt that as a
unqualified I've always felt that as
someone with no who's never played video
games held a controller or done research
with it at all
I've always felt that like he's so ahead
of his time I've always had an intuition
that instead of gun control I've never
thought to myself how are these young
kids getting possession of assault
rifles and tons of ammo and bump stocks
and huge magazines I've always thought
to myself no it's the violent video
games
this guy has never [ __ ] played a
video game in his life ever look how
cool this is [ __ ] crusty old [ __ ]
there's we watched from studies shown
but really which one does to individuals
when you look at these photos of how it
took place you can see the actions
within videogames so it's just vile eyes
it's violence and what study has even
thought the opposite is true every time
they've studied this they buy no
connection between being violent just
look at the stats you don't need any any
study it's all right there in front of
us the best counter I've ever seen this
trip you know chart right here
videogames per person that they spent to
violent gun deaths South Korea China
even more than the United States almost
no gun deaths United well I mean clearly
just look USA is the total outlier here
Japan Italy Spain France Germany Canada
United States our United Kingdom's all
huge consumers of video games does
anyone else have gun deaths do you know
what it is likely linked to the
availability of guns well this shows
there is no correlation at all no
correlation none but if you look at the
vicina if you look at the scene of the
violence you could clearly tell that
it's something out of a video game
people never died before
video games were around and you know
world war ii was a war of well it was a
different time hmm some people say that
Hitler went back in time and played
video games and that was a cause for
what worked oh [ __ ] this guy so anyway
here's douche number one there's but
what I'd like to do is make sure just
get all the facts where they're
indications and there's times before
that we have found this and there's
times a foreign that we've proven we
could come together just in the last
Congress we found that there was a
shooting in Texas that an individual
should not have been able to have that
weapon because he was dishonorably
discharged because there was abuse with
inside that
he he did within his own family but we
found that the knick the National
instant criminal background check we
came together to make sure that it was
our own military was not putting that
forward giving the information at the
time that that could have been stopped
is that weapon or trying to talk him out
what he's saying is basically what I'm
trying to say is I'm trying to figure
out what I can say to make it sound like
I care and I want to do anything but in
a week I want to ensure that I won't
forget about this and nothing happens
because frankly speaking we all receive
lots of millions of dollars of money
from the NRA and well we'd be really
[ __ ] if that ever stops coming in
probably not reelected so the cost of a
couple dead children well it's really
probably video games if anything here
there's more Fox News once again Ted
Williams let's have a look here old
Teddy Boy you know I wonder if if these
guys who very often are raised on a diet
of violent video games oh yes they yeah
if they actually start pulling the
trigger of a real weapon and they see
real death and they find that it's not
as satisfying as as maybe it was when
they're playing it on a television
screen what are you even listen to you
all these geniuses have got these
theories they don't even play video
games they just wander he goes it's not
as satisfying so why would they go kill
people
his theory doesn't even have you ever
encountered that and and could that be
the reason that that this guy just
finally stopped
well I've encountered video game players
and and their activity but it's read at
individuals act out like this there are
video gamers I think it's a little too
early to speculate at this stage about
the motives but what we do this guy's
like wow really yeah here's another one
from guess where Fox News
right it's almost like they've got an
agenda I were a betting man I'd say that
he probably lost six to eight hours a
day
playing one of those you know six day
try 10:00 to 12:00 [ __ ] video games
were you doing - nothing but
dehumanizing people by blowing their
heads out blowing their heads off one
after another after another because it
does seem to desensitize some of these
killers - I love how scientifically well
it does seem yeah isn't this the same
guy that was asking the other dude
everybody on Fox News looks the same I
can write Ichiro's I'm actually what
happens when you pull a trigger and that
is the talking it's just you know these
guys you guys know that in the morning
all these fox news anchors get a memo
that says talk about pointing guns at
people in real life is desensitized from
playing violent video games they keep
repeating the same lines - it's telling
for the last 25 years we have been are
the parenting method in this count in
this country has been very soft and
there haven't been a lot of when you
start shooting them threatening them at
gunpoint parents need guns really like
you know how to prevent these shootings
really sure parents with will shoot the
shooter they go they've been talking
about how arming teachers they want to
do that yeah when you start arming
Walmart employees because how are we
gonna prevent that well all Walmart
managers get to carry around a handgun
now love it everybody that is actively
engaging in something that causes you to
dehumanize people for hours and hours it
really are you an expert lady do you
have some qualification methods a former
FBI agent
to be looked at and it's something that
we've seen several former active
shooters she got she got that wall to
have been retired from the FBI huh you
know what I mean she's a little young to
be retired from the FBI she's like and
what division were you in in the FBI
well I can't talk about it she's like
what's she was like uh agriculture you
know what I mean oh yeah perfect well
let's see there's another one here if
you believe that this is a clip of Trump
let's see lieutenant governor Dan
Patrick of Texas also blaming videogames
on what network is this how can i I'm
gonna be that they're all happening on
the same network like they had a memo in
a talking point to try to confuse the
time will act and let's condemn it for
what it is
evil are evil and I and I say how long
are we gonna last an example and ignore
at the federal level particularly yes
where they can say something about the
video game that we believe is from
shooting this manifesto he talks about
living out his Super Soldier fantasy
someone debunk all that studies it says
it does not but I look at the common
denominators as sixty so yeah his his
manifesto said something to the effect
of you know remember it is not cowardly
to pick low-hanging free fruit okay
don't attack heavily guarded areas to
fulfill your Super Soldier Cod fantasy
so he's basically encouraging other
people to like not try and act out your
videogame fantasy rather you should go
shoot up a Walmart cool guy really
really great advice there so you're
saying I attack low security target yeah
he's essentially saying the exact
opposite of what the go in the game yeah
he wasn't trying he's saying don't try
and act out your Super Soldier fantasy
it's literally the opposite of what he
just said in that clip so there you go
by the way you know how we used to be
like don't even name the shooter because
if we don't want to give them any
notoriety there's so many of them now
you're no one special anymore go shoot
up a [ __ ] Walmart nobody even gives a
[ __ ] about you I didn't even heard the
guy's name once because there's so many
of you pathetic losers well now they're
now the new annoying thing is that they
called their little write-up and
manifesto yeah well guess what it's just
a bunch of [ __ ] nobody [ __ ] cares
about and nobody even remembers your
name because your your your there's
thousands of you idiots now it used to
be we'd be like oh this was his name and
this was it's like dude you're not that
smell waiting for ya you're not that
special anymore you [ __ ] loser ass
[ __ ] you can go sit at the loser table
in hell you know what I mean there's
like a lunch table in hell for all these
loser ass shooters I bet you at the
loser table in hell they're all playing
Magic the Gathering but they're out of
like trap cards I don't know anything
about magic sorry two people who play
Magic Yugi oh there's no trap cards in
magic really there isn't maybe there is
I haven't played magic since lame ooh
I'm sorry to interrupt this guy's
manifesto this guy's got a little math
as to him zone we've always had guns
we've always had evil but what's changed
where we see this rash of shooting bro
are you so [ __ ] dumb do you
understand that every kid plays video
games you could say that about anything
oh these kids today are ditching school
it must the common denominator video
games
what percentage of kids are playing
video games around that age 100% of all
kids are playing video games man you
really are dumb as it gets even if you
want to make the argument that it's like
you know 0.1% of people that play this
are like desensitized by it I mean you
can make that argument so many things I
mean should we we should outlaw alcohol
because people get violent when they
drink alcohol
a tiny sliver of people do so let's just
ban alcohol Oh movie yeah what about
violent movies done that's what it used
to be nobody talks about that anymore
wasn't it also like they used to talk
about music like that yeah heavy metal
yeah yeah but again ignoring the fact
that all kids are listening to [ __ ]
the same music dude I mean all you have
to see is this I really this is the
start and stop of this theory yeah
that's it dude if game video games make
people violent these you would not see
this you would see a linear correlation
I mean dude it's not rocket science even
Neil deGrasse Tyson could do a little
write-up about this and well well you
see at a hundred thousand people I don't
know what this means oh one per 100,000
yeah that's nothing why we even worry
about this and I and I see a video game
industry that that teaches young people
to kill you know in his manifesto he
said he this is not a Republican or
Democrat thing because he was concerned
about robots and environment and and
immigrants obviously a hate crime I
think in in my view against immigrants
from this man just Michael we haven't
had an official report on that and I
don't mean to talk on but I've just my
heart is so heavy this morning because I
think yes where are we as a country I
look at social media the violence of
just bullying people on social media
every day and we turn our head and we
and we allow it on a Sunday morning one
most of your viewers right now half of
the country are getting ready to go to
church and and yet tomorrow we won't let
our kids even pray in our schools well
we have a really good point he's making
his heart is heavy because we're all
going to church on Sunday yeah we won't
even let our kids pray in our schools
and that and it's God God has noticed
this and sent these shooters to punish
us and then finally if it couldn't get
any better
the President himself after watching Fox
News all day has decided he knows why
these shootings are taking we must seek
real bipartisan solutions we have to do
what in a bipartisan manner that will
truly make America safer and better for
all first we must do a better job of
identifying and acting on early warning
signs I am directing the Department of
Justice to work in partisan partnership
with local state and federal agencies as
well as social media companies to
develop tools that can detect mass
shooters before they strike the monster
in the Parkland High School in Florida
had many red flags against him and yet
nobody wanted a monitor nobody did
anything you know why not got to prevent
the second we must stop the
glorification of violence in our society
this includes the gruesome and grisly
video games that's number two now
commonplace it is too easy today for
troubled youth to surround themselves
with a culture that celebrates violence
we must start for substantially reduce
this and it has to begin immediately
cultural change is hard but each of so
that was number two on his list is
violent video games so I think that I
don't see the little bit of a problem
yeah these shootings are gonna keep
happening that's let's soldier on shall
we yeah Brazilian drug lord tries to
escape prison I mean obviously I got to
talk about this story captured the the
mind and imagination of the world huh
Brazilian gang leader has been caught
trying to escape from jail disguised as
teenage daughter now there's something
about this guy's plan that doesn't make
sense to me yeah
his 18 year old daughter comes to visit
him and he left her in the prison cell
did you not think that through because
II don't know what was the plan I was
confused by that too well so what
happened was that well they caught him
and
they arrested his daughter for being an
accomplice but even if he escaped she
would have still been an accomplice and
they would have put her in jail yeah I
mean then are we getting it right is
that yeah I mean I the only thing I can
imagine is you know he leaves and then
she also leaves and hopes that nobody
notices that the same person left twice
like she's right oh I guess he's like
hey guys I'm in the cell right yeah I'm
not not in the cell how would she get
into the cell it would have been in the
like the visitor area yes
so they both walk out right that's
separate but that's a pretty brilliant
yeah I guess she was just gonna leave
later but the people watching you know
President as far as I'm aware is uh yeah
they know who's coming and going and
that's kind of the main function of a
prison right you could say that so
anyway he really goes full mission
possible man he's coming that's
impressive
yeah by the way what is this outfit it's
18 year old girl not a 12 year old man
like a Mickey Mouse love shirt on man
this has got to be the first time notice
they said his nervousness gave them away
crazy
well the mask looks really I mean it's
good enough at a glance I guess if they
weren't looking closely you're probably
pass his face did he ever bra yeah what
what's the point of but look at his face
when he takes this off you I almost
accept him to be smiling like you got me
but he's like yeah he's that guy was
apparently so this story takes a great
little turn here I mean I'm great I mean
it's depressing here there's more good
pictures before we get to the pressing
part of this story that's
here look at this you uh you want to
laugh but uh oh my goodness so crazy oh
yeah that's it
damn that's a first for the world
minutes in genius in a way the dude
wearing the bra do this you know I guess
he went to the bathroom she but how did
she bring in all this yeah huh this was
a complicated plan mm-hmm so you know in
a twist of fate he
this is almost too too depressing to
read he killed himself he [ __ ] hung
himself all right the next day
apparently his his daughter got thrown
in prison and he was found three days
after the failed attempt hanging from
bedsheets so that is not helping this
episode which we're trying to work night
and and on top of it his 19 year old
daughter is now in prison for yeah kind
of backfired he was serving a 73 year
sentence on drug trafficking charges
that's pretty steep on drug trafficking
and [ __ ] around in Brazil yeah I'm uh
remind me never go to Brazil
oh there's everyone go all the comments
are but the bra so funny like wig works
I guess glasses help mask creepy but
obviously necessary jacket clearly also
necessary shirt cute bra what this guy
just wanted to explore on his life his
last chance
no the bra makes sense to me give a
little extra all right he's going in
that far myself throw on a bra I don't
know it seems unnecessary because you
had a jacket over but there was no
finding him down I don't know I'm down
with the bra I'm
and now we go to our lead story actually
we have a lot left we got the end dating
game okay here we go
this this has got to be one of the most
epic fails of all time in the history of
all of YouTube you guys probably heard
about this a girl accidentally uploaded
an unedited video of her abusing her dog
and this is a girl who basically
acquired a Doberman puppy about a month
ago and since then she's been making
pretty much she was like a beauty
vlogger or something and she's been
making videos with her puppy since then
and they've been performing much better
than her usual content so she's been
making lots of videos happy-go-lucky
videos with her new puppy until let me
show you this this is interesting okay
because she she uploaded the unedited
one erased it and then uploaded it the
one that she was meant to upload and so
what you'll see I want to show you first
is the edited version okay so that you
can write Harrison yeah this is the
version she meant to upload so here you
go
so sweet I love that dog
pretty smart honestly how he can tell
you the plastic like totally not pasta
crap she's trying to prank the dog but
it looks like they're having fun and you
know what can you say it they're having
a good time and she's doing little
[Music]
that's it okay now this is in one of the
most epic youtube fez of all time she
accidentally uploads the wrong video the
unedited or raw file which was quickly
captured by Internet sleuths hmm and
here by the way can I show this because
I saw the original video was taken down
yeah I mean it's not really that graphic
is it it's on that graphic I mean we
should at least give a heads if if
you're really bothered by seeing an
animal abuse and I'm not going the dog
is fine because it's a huge dog and the
dogs disposition is this happy loving
carefree dog so what you're about to see
some hitting and just just mean behavior
but obviously she's not really capable
of hurting the dog no it's really just
like physically yeah it's really just
the attitude of the girl so I think it's
safe to watch I don't really think it's
like really I think it's more just about
that attitude yeah I only say that
because her original video was taken
down I think in the conversation yeah
it's fine yeah the dog jumped on her
like playfully and she slapped it in the
head no
doc do you upload this I know that's so
[ __ ] unbelievably stupid this is her
brand-new puppy she's only had for one
month okay she spit on her [ __ ] dog
she said in her apology she didn't spit
on well he did he spit on your dog it
was off slightly off camera but but
there's there's literally nothing yeah
it is it's hilariously psycho spitting
on your dog she's denying that she did
it yeah yeah she is
she says because it's off-camera so I
guess she I mean the only it's either
she spit or she punched it in the face
like which one it's worse you can see
her like thrust her right forward but
he's like trying to play with her yeah
well in the tone of the video surprising
that they're having fun it's playtime
yeah and so now the dogs trying to play
with her and by the way this is a tiny
apartment I can tell an adult man has a
big [ __ ] dog they have a lot of energy
to get out and so especially as a puppy
I can only imagine pick up this dog is
so he's got a lot of energy and he wants
to play and he's in a really playful
happy mood she spit on us
[Music]
that friend is such a psycho thing I
can't get over the fact she spit on the
dog and then uploaded it that's the best
part right that she uploaded this yeah
the guy who's recording it is just
recording the TV's the monitors probably
because he's just like oh [ __ ]
imagine oh this is someone recording
yeah just imagine you're a fan of hers
and then this is like yeah oh my god
it's like what is got the alert on your
phone yeah oh yeah let's check this out
pretty wild - how she turns it on and
off yeah this is like YouTube's weird
man YouTube's weird so awful I mean you
can't really I don't know gives me the
creeps
maybe this job's not for you I don't
know I think it's not we love you we
love you like she hates him but also
what's wrong with the dog being playful
in this shot isn't that a good shot
isn't that even a good job yeah and it
is a video about playing with the what
why are you even upset look at this this
is great look how cute he is
he just looked you in the face he's
trying to play this dog so awesome yeah
she's awful she's saying her her mouth
is clenched so you can't hear but she's
saying lay down
[Music]
so this video blew up and actually I
strangely I don't know what happened but
I had my first reaction when I saw this
was like I will cuz me and you are
thinking about getting another dog
anyway
mm-hmm so ice tweeted at her and I got a
[ __ ] lot of attention 62,000 likes
now said I'm in LA because I saw she
lives in LA and I will literally buy
your dog from you name any price he
really needs a new home and I was 100%
serious now the crazy thing
I followed her so she could Danny I said
you know my dams are open to you message
me I'm hunter sent serious and she did
DM me she said hello would you be
willing to talk for a moment and I was
like wow is this actually gonna happen
and I said hey what's up I'm understand
serious give if you give me your number
we can speak over the phone and she
never responded to me so and I mean you
can see I I responded to her only 30
minutes after she says oh yeah I know
what happened but I'm pretty sure things
got a little heated because there is
another article that came out that the
LAPD is opening a case about animal
abuse on her they basically just said
they didn't say give any information
they only confirmed that they opened an
investigation into her so [ __ ] crazy
oh I'm in this article that's cool look
at me
oh I didn't read her apology and her
apology was so bad do it oh my god it's
kind of long but the tone is based she
doesn't even well here let me read the
first one cuz she goes yeah yeah she
goes first of all let me say that on
that day I was actually having a less
than exceptional week
I'm not gonna play the victim card but I
will but I do want to point out that I'm
rarely as upset as what you see the
bubbly happy-go-lucky girl that you see
in the videos is an accurate
representation of me really do you spit
on your [ __ ] dog if you do that once
dude that being said this does not
justify me yelling at my dog look she
doesn't acknowledge hitting him she goes
yelling that's all she says and I'm
fully of where that should have gotten
his angers I didn't know she I've raised
my voice and yelled at him no however
when my 75 pound Doberman is jumping in
my face with his mouth open I do as a
dog parent have to show him that this
behavior is unacceptable
I saw him lick your face lady yeah I'll
go but I want to make it known
regardless of what my dog does I should
have not acted that way towards him all
she says is yelling she's trying to act
like she's saying I do want to clarify
that I'm not a dog abuser not a dog
abuser animal geezer in any way shape or
form anyone who's witness or her true
animal abuse will be able to clearly see
that no I don't know what animal well
was it but she says that she didn't spit
on him yes she goes here she goes let me
scan she says oh did I spit on my dog
she justifies it by saying if he was
audibly or physically in pain it would
be a different story and you would hear
it I also did not spit on my dog but I
understand how could look like that did
I get in his face and take a necessary
action toward him yes I did and that was
not the way I should have handled this
is ruin but I spit on him no what did
you do in that moment if not spit on him
she says my family are in the process of
getting a trainer but it's very
expensive mm-hmm don't get a dog then
yeah sure you're not gonna be able to
handle it yeah she is a really and then
she also says that he has a lot of toys
as if that makes it matter
yeah a dog like that needs to exercise
like an hour a day at least the toy
doesn't do anything unless someone is
playing with him with the toy you have a
toy dog honest she ends it by saying on
a serious note this is the new thing by
the way this is what Neal's this is how
Neil apologized till they go I just want
to thank you for pointing out that
things that you think are wrong
discussing that because the world needs
more of that I hope you give me a chance
to prove that these statements about
myself do align with my action I love
that this is the new apology thank you
you and MA and finally I want to thank
you you for bringing this up and making
the world a better place
thank you yeah you're not fooling anyone
but I I had a feeling that she wasn't
going to actually offer for me to adopt
her dog anyway she was probably just
trying to prevent I stopped this episode
of the right now although I'm I'm not
even talking about this as as currently
I mean most people have already
eviscerated her mm-hmm I didn't want to
like a visitor cuz I wanted to leave the
door open for actually adopting the dog
I
if there is that door open I mean I'm
still I am 100% willing I have a big
house I've got a big yard I've got a the
means well we take care of that big dog
park and all the time and we have
another dog that has got a ton of energy
she'll burn that [ __ ] off good the first
thing I saw when I saw that dog was like
oh my god he would be so good with
shredder they would go crazy together
the reason we want another one is
because we feel so bad that we don't
have as much time for shredder no with
tutoring so we want to get him a
playmate mm-hmm so god this girl's life
is [ __ ] oh I'm sure of it mm-hmm so
the LAPD is investigating her man
crazy huh she pretty much disappeared
off the face of the planet
she goes I think everyone who's been
kind of understanding I really
appreciate it I don't know who she's
referring to really I'll come in this
[ __ ] some people are really take it too
far
yeah that's there's no way we're gonna
kill yourself it's like no no that's
that's really not the point here I
always hate seeing that let's not tell
people to kill themselves she's still
redeemable human being
I mean she didn't commit genocide she
just needs some anger management mm-hmm
and and let me clarify I think that
she's capable of loving her dog and and
you know wishing well for her dog she
has anger problems
yeah uh severe anger problems and some
kind of trauma that she needs a fix
she's a redeemable human being she
shouldn't kill right I mean she didn't
do anything she didn't listen listen
clever I mean again she's not a murderer
she's not a rapist she didn't really
harm the dog irreparably although that's
not a healthy home for a dog what I
witnessed she needs to address her own
issues no you know we need to tone down
we need to tone it down a little bit
here she's a redeemable human being guys
I mean come on right I agree yeah
it's important to say it I mean we all
go through dark times and lows we are
all capable of improving ourselves in
yeah and when you have something going
on and you're unstable it's so easy to
be to become mean towards someone or
something yeah definitely you know if we
had a slice of all of our worst points
uploaded to the internet unedited but
that's what's so epic about this
uploaded that yeah I just I I can't wrap
my head around how that even happens as
well you constantly puts things up on
YouTube it's like you don't even like
look at it for like half a second the
wrong footage the only thing I can think
of is that the clip she uploaded was
closed in the duration of time they're
both very short files yeah about nothing
to do and I think that was probably some
kind of export that wasn't the whole
shoot so that's the only thing I can
imagine but you can see this is the
first video she made with her puppy
mm-hmm name the life of my Doublemint
puppy from one month ago so this is a
new adoption and every video she's made
with the dog since then has gotten way
like the one with the thumbnail has
helped me with an arrow point but look
at this first video look how many cuts
there
like I just wonder if she's speeding the
[ __ ] out of it during that month you
know during this part that she cut out I
know why I just I don't think you can
really get a dog that size in a in that
tiny apartment all the time in New York
I'll let you have to know that you have
a huge your dog requires a lot of
exercise yeah so you got to bust that
dog's ass during the day yeah otherwise
he's gonna lose his mind in that little
apartment right that's right well Brooke
my door is open my dams are open if you
do watch this that would be a very happy
ending
I would love to adopt your dog and I
will compensate you for it I know those
that puppy probably cost you a pretty
penny a purebred Doberman I will pay you
for everything you've spent on that dog
fully reimburse you and you can rehab
know that he's got a happy home here so
I hope you'll do the right thing here
you know I don't know what she's gonna
do with that dog or just get some help
well either way I don't think the
situation's good for that dog I mean how
can she go on now but it's so sad you
know it's I don't know it's up anyway
lot's of luck did lots of look Ian
dating game green shirt guy Ian dating
game let's do the green shirt guy than
the Ian dating game to close it out
green shirt guy this was a really
popular meme and I did I was like what
the [ __ ] going on green shirt guy was
trending that's that green shirt guy oh
that what so I look it up and here it is
so this maggot girl is interrupting some
kind of public hearing City huh City
hearing and protesting immigration oh no
dude you have to admit even if you're a
trump supporter there's something
particularly trashy about wearing that
hat yes I mean look at this
have you ever seen a trashy air image in
your life and you couldn't say all you
want about Donald Trump and think he's
the greatest but I have to tell you that
read make America great again hat
immediately hits the trash points up by
fifty thirteen million views I can't
play the [ __ ] video
[Music]
I mean her outfit is enough respect our
lodge or we will deport you her shirts
look at her best by the way by the way I
got to go back for a second cousin her
homey who's there protesting with her
got a big slurp in his hand and he won't
put it down he won't put it down he's
chewing on something and he's got a
[ __ ] big slurp from Chevron and he
will put it down
oh stop rewarding start deporting it
says and so this homing the greed sure
as you'll see starts cracking up and my
god I mean that Chevron cup probably is
what it is
yeah what's with the big thing so the
laughter I guess is what sealed him as
their Twitter hero for the day but we've
got a whole write-up on him
so let's let's set the stage a little
bit we actually filmed some video give a
little background of what was happening
at that City Council meeting here's a
dude playing a banjo and this is really
like Parks and Recreation come to life
isn't it this was part of the same
meeting some homie and out overalls with
a banjo and big beard this really
people's lives what is going on there I
think people that regularly go to town
these halls yes I think this is a slice
of reality sweet that here's another one
part of the same meeting yeah he's a
sweet guy is someone singing a
couple of older ladies well you would
expect to see really hold are hippies
[Music]
clapping
offbeat right off the beat there's two
one I notice the clapping stuff I get
the they didn't have too much time to
reverse that but anyway this is the
setting and you know god bless them for
participating democracy in action right
there these are the people that really
make the decisions on the ground so the
couple that interrupted are a couple
that are well known for doing
anti-immigration activism in Arizona and
first getting big slurps from Chevron a
coalition of churches wants a federal
judge to order the groups to stay off
their property oh wait there's a whole
thing here the woman which is a
right-wing extremist group a patriot
movement of Arizona she's currently
being sued by several groups according
to Arizona public media a lawsuit was
filed against them alleging they
threatening harass people who help
migrants dropped off at churches by
federal authorities a coalition of
churches wants a federal judge to order
the group to stay off their property and
keep a distance that collusion includes
the Southern Poverty Law Center do you
have anything better to do these people
work
no this is this is their free time so
what'd you do for fun they're probably
trying to earn a buck from the [ __ ] you
know posted on YouTube we've got to go
find Richard get some exactly exactly
patreon
green shirt guy Alex kak they're part of
their writer and comedian he was
interviewed by the news and had this to
say it's an incredibly dark time and
there's a lot of hateful rhetoric but
ultimately I think the majority of this
country regardless of their political
affiliation understands that the loudest
voice is happening right now are kind of
ridiculous
and I think that that laughter is
resonating because I think that's kind
of how people feel right now
amen brother to the green shirt now I
want to I have a question for backstage
that was very quiet in here
so for our audience was that not quiet
so that video was panned hard to the
right for some reason there was no left
channel so we quickly panned it over to
the other channel so the audience should
be able to hear it okay
how is there possibly an ant in my water
yeah there you have it so that's it oh
no no that's not it I have some bonus
some bonus videos adding on the school
scooter people are brazii okay you guys
are gonna like this we did a story
recently about how scooter scooter
people lost their damn minds
well I've got a ad on here folks on the
top it's a scooter person at a skate
park and he's trying to hit this round
and he [ __ ] flips
homie it's trying to hit a ramp it's not
that way isn't that a lady I think
they're trying to take a shortcut
possibly cuz the ramp she's going up
deep it's really not that steep but you
know these scooters are not meant for
and valid brutal when I look to your
doctor she's got a bunch of [ __ ] in
there basket he's got a ton of fit in
her basket that comes spilling out onto
the floor
and she really just eats [ __ ] man
backwards for crazy dudes like when they
all sound they got a scooter and they
think they can do anything
exactly that's what I'm saying
they think they got this super power now
it's just a scooter did that thing
doesn't even have enough horsepower like
as its limitations
she couldn't even hit like a 5 degree
incline without flipping backwards and
so that's bonus clip number one bonus
clip number two coming at you is a curse
Tik Tok that I saw
apparently this ladies has a account I
don't I think she's Indian why why
because I think there's some cultural
thing that I'm missing here and because
she seems to have a heavy accent and
something has clearly lost in
translation here ok you tell me what it
is
[Music]
come on get my foot massage
[Music]
what a - [ __ ]
just watch so this one was got a bunch
of is I don't know then what I did
you're on your own on this one no that
was [ __ ] weird that's a curse for you
did that that Twitter account
1.2 million everything about this I have
a sprained girl I need a massage and
then she looks at the camera like god I
[Music]
don't know why this woman's like her
daughter's crying and [ __ ] was acting I
know but why does this character want a
massage so bad on the bonus video stage
we have a happy happy ending what does
this stand we actually just I didn't
know that you had another scooter video
this was oh we have another scooter
video Todd oh we have we have a
submission for Zach dad your dad sent
this [ __ ] huh it is also scooter related
although not a mobility scooter to be
fair this is one of the birds scooters a
little violent
it's less violent than the other one
that's real not as good donors good you
know what's not as good and I'll tell
you why
well there's a thousand reasons why it's
just I fell it's not an epic fail yeah
it's not an epic fail I mean there you
can't beat the mobility scooter flipping
backwards in a skate park for sure you
know that's that's talking to your gate
part and then her baskets full of [ __ ]
and it's bells everywhere shouldn't have
started with that yes that was that was
hard to beat that's a premium but I mean
that's it's good Thank You Todd Thank
You Todd and finally so I guess this is
our fourth bonus video and you guys are
really gonna love this one this is not
this is just wholesome as it gets you
all know I'm obsessed with this Turkish
chef Susan says and I don't know seesee
in this in Buraq I call him Susan Susan
okay we can calm says him either goes
why don't why doesn't he have English
subtitles I says I'm the only person
outside Turkey that's washing him but
this videos epic is [ __ ] and by the way
just to show you how popular this guy's
it is almost 5 million views on
Instagram but this video is epic
[Music]
yo so subscribe yeah dude his driving
I'm an Iron Man flies up to the window
he's actually driving and moving mask is
down he hands him a plate of food the
mask goes up and who was it food boy
with a big smile
waving helmet goes down he flies off you
have to see it really that's a great
helmet oh my god that helmets badass
yeah I was like really elaborate he's
what it starts with him watching a video
and be like I am so hungry
sh free podcasts that was amazing yeah
[Laughter]
well we talked about it all we did it
all so are we gonna address our en
applications oh no we didn't do it all
but to say although we could save that
for Tuesday oh let's save it for Tuesday
and if anyone's listening who wants to
add their application we are gonna be
doing a ian dating game now let me just
give you instructions because some girls
got cut because they're clearly just
trying to promote their Instagram I will
tell you the girls are making it to the
show itself are the ones to put in more
effort the ones that are serious about
actually wanting to go on a date with
the in this is not a joke I am not
calling to promote this is serious yeah
if I sense that you are seriously
interested in Ian that there could be
possibly a true love connection then I
want to see your resume if you want to
just show me cleavage and try to promote
your Instagram then I'm sorry but what
but and for those reasons I'm out yeah
we have roses that were actually going
to be handing out like bachelor style so
send in your applications to podcasts
and h3h3 broker's com
if you want to be a part of that Ian or
how are you feeling you excited I think
there might be a match
for you that was pretty excited for you
don't use that ever again that drop I
hate it why do you wait so much
wait what I need to pee so bad I hate it
too I'll tell you why because it sounds
like he was actually saying but it's
kind of become funny because he hates it
so much can we have an executive order
to delete this in this is way too funny
because it bothers him so but wait so
you and Zach are for it what about then
cuz then could be the no I'm a hundred
percent with Ethan if it didn't bother
him I would say yeah no because and why
does it bother you so much because it's
fake news I'm not yeah the side can't
tell that it's a sound I like it now at
first the first time I heard it I was
like what the [ __ ]
like why would that be on there because
I actually thought Ian said it exactly
but now that I know them now that I know
the gaff they're gonna stay so bad it
must stay and it must be used more I'm
good luck bring it on bring a hammer in
you it's on the internet dude okay but
don't worry about that and we have got a
great episode plan for you Tuesday we're
gonna find you love we're gonna we're
gonna be I'll have a whole dating show I
think it was your idea in to name it the
bachelor with h3 3 instead of E yes
exactly
someone suggested that I can okay I got
a piece so I don't Zack is loving it
you're gonna have to cut this is like
bowling come on Ian it's good we're
gonna dude I have a feeling that we're
gonna you could find something special I
have a question for Zack
yes how is the relationship with your
dad been rocky painted is Zach's dad is
helping us find our home and he's been
feeding he's a realtor and he's been
feeding us info about Zach and then he
crossed the line I guess recently he
provided some information to me to even
me I was like that seemed a little
personal the Lord he went in his bedroom
I took pictures and stuff and I was like
whoa I was like you know I'm not gonna
talk about this but then I showed it to
Zach so I just want him to know that
because dad is a double agent I mean I
feel so bad crying no it was it was he
was he really I can't imagine my dad
ever actually feeling sad about anything
he did to me to the point of crying
that's really sweet he really cares
about you yeah yeah I think he just
wanted to be part of the show you know
he wanted to be in on the goose you know
and he was enjoying kind of being part
of the narrative I think he's excited
for you though he's really happy for you
yeah of atad him talk he's at he comes
in he's a tall guy with a little Fupa
and he was all tucked and really high
high so I said I was a Todd and talk
like dad why are you wearing it up to
your nipples today it was legit like
over his bellybutton not up to the neck
because he wants to hide his muffin top
[Music]
when you tuck up to the bellybutton
I'll talked in it doesn't hide it
accentuates I will be sure to toe we all
got eyes there's no hiding and you're my
client
I mean he'll leave the house sometimes
is exactly don't look fat today what
would you got any dirt on your dad you
want to make even here and then I have
to think about that yeah we should vet
this off yeah we should better I don't
want to cause any further rifts in the
family I did already cost you break up
with your girlfriend no no no no
Bell asked about you no she didn't
yeah I'm kidding she asked if you could
send her a job your spit
how's everyone else doing everything
good yeah we're doing good we're doing
real good back here did I take it too
far with the political you guys boy how
you guys support me on my political you
know maybe we should have peppered in
the goofs a little bit more evenly
throughout the episode cuz uh but that's
what's kind of a dark episode but but
how can you go from like talking about
shooting to like a scooter yeah that's
kind of true I don't see any other way
to do it you know it's fine sometimes
you gotta face the facts yeah worlds of
dark place I got a piece well let's see
his face well yeah he's in charge huh
yeah it's not reciprocated I have to
make it up the end just kidding can I
bring you roses I'm not giving you so
good
no I didn't I don't I'm sure we'll have
to start calling in like a bit like and
you have to pee Ian do you need to go
bathroom I got a piece right well that's
about it how are you scared oh we're
doing good how are you doing here fine
exhausting yeah well you're doing good
I thought you were getting all the
smiles this morning I was getting smiles
I was doing this
okay he loves that and then I tried and
started crying what was that about
no he's mom team mom for sure did those
pictures you guys posted it at the pool
day picture of him and that swimsuit
yeah pretty good crazy yeah no he's he's
the man a little teddy but I am ready to
go enjoy my weekend as I'm sure all of
you are so with that I wish you a fond
bon voyage until Tuesday
au revoir au revoir as the French say au
as the Italian said bye sayonara really
say Ian's got to go to the bathroom so
we better wrap it up yeah and can you
hold it honest man why dude we had a
break
literally piping of music just hold it
alright
just hold it for another 30 seconds
we're almost done geez this silence back
there is definite have a great weekend
guys we'll see on Tuesday thank you for
the great week we had a terrific week
here with the yang gang I'm yanking all
the way I I donated a hundred bucks
nice I did it so generous I know I'm
feel like a [ __ ] Saint when I donated
I was like I am I am contributing
nothing I'm so happy that I you know but
I am the gang gang I think if there's
any other nominees maybe we could reach
out try to get him on here if Jo got
Bernie I think we got a shot mmm you
think so mom or I don't know percent
shot let's say that more than zero well
yeah I mean that yeah well according to
Neil deGrasse Tyson you have a better
shot of dying from the flu than getting
burning yeah yeah
all right let's wrap this [ __ ] up guys
love you appreciate justing on Tuesday
have a great weekend stay blessed stay
blank and watch out for those bullets
dude on whose date you gotta be [ __ ]
dodging bullets like neo from the matrix
all right we'll see you next week